a lingering and painful death for a pair
of dogs
police confirmed two young dogs died of
heat exhaustion over the weekend
at a home near tropicana and rainbow
their owner arrested now facing cruelty
charges
madison kimbrell live tonight with
neighbors reaction and what pet owners
are required to do
during excessive heat madison
yeah denise it's a simple concept if
it's hot outside
leave your animals inside and it reaches
over 105 degrees
us pet owners need to do more to make
sure that they are ok
now in this case that didn't happen
because one woman is now in custody
after leaving her two dogs in a hot
garage with no food
or water we've had multiple dogs that
have already died in the last few weeks
in this extreme heat and anyone that
would keep them in the garage
you know it's just unfathomable
on monday animal control found two pit
bulls dead inside of a southwest valley
garage
the dogs died a horrible death due
to be locked up in a hot
probably airless garage no food no water
is even worse
and i have no idea how long they were in
there thirty-year-old aisha hill owned
the dogs
she's facing two counts of animal abuse
according to police reports one of the
dogs had cuts on its snout
police believe it was trying to dig into
the concrete floor to find
cooler air i just think that it's just
unfair neighbor carson mitma owns a
six-year-old pitbull named bullet
he says the breed already goes through
so much so this hits close to home
pit bulls and themselves have like had
to come out of this hole of like you
know being seen as these dog fighting
dogs but in reality you know they're
probably some of the sweetest dogs that
i know
animal activists hope that this case
brings up felony charges
with that lady we were glad to see that
someone was held accountable
and in las vegas a new ordinance means
that if it reaches over 105 degrees
that pet owners must provide cooling
stations for their animals so that's
misters or fans and if the national
weather service
issues a heat warning that means all
animals must stay
indoors they are not allowed outside
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now